even with all the famous faces in
cocaine bear Tom the EMT is still a
total scene stealer you've probably seen
him before but not in any movies in this
review of cocaine bear the Associated
Press called the movie A mashup of
Quentin Tarantino bloodfest some Remy's
Scare Tactics and the coven brothers
absurdity that is if you can believe it
a negative review for the cocaine bear
demographic AKA lovers of Bears and the
cinema AP accidentally dropped an
enticing endorsement even cocaine bear
producer Phil Lord accepted the ap's pan
as PR Mana from Heaven tweeting we are
putting this on the poster the very
premise of cocaine bear is a seat filler
in and of itself Elizabeth Banks film
was Lucy based in a 1985 incident where
in a black bear ingested copious amounts
of cocaine and died soon after let's see
what kind of effect that has on
the Gonzo Hollywood retelling as drug
dealers Chase scenes and enough fake
blood to make Tarantino and raymie blush
sweetening the pot as a movie stacked
ensemble cast cocaine bear is filled
with big-name stars who have been acting
for decades Tom the EMT on the other
hand you might recognize from your cell
phone Scott sees as a baltimore-born
comedian who Rose to fame with his viral
angry retail Guy character that has
taken Tick Tock by storm cocaine Bears a
comedian's feature film debut as he
nabbed the part with the casting
director's assistant messaged him on
Facebook asking him to audition cease
seemed to relish the part he also
appreciated that the role didn't
pigeonhole him as a Tick-Tock star he
told on Milwaukee they were super
collaborative and I was treated just
like any other actor on the set doing
work it wasn't just like a joke part
indeed as Tom the EMT sees plays one of
many characters who's a victim to the
Bear's coke-fueled ire sees may have
shared a gruesome scene with Margot
Martindale but he still hasn't forgotten
his social media media Roots the
comedian took to Twitter to helpfully
explain that cocaine bear viewers need
not prepare by studying up on convoluted
IP or decades Old Source material if
you've ever heard the words cocaine or
bear before you're completely up to
speed Scott sees has a mask quite a
sizable following on Tick Tock currently
standing at 1.7 million followers while
many people likely follow him for his
hilarious sketches poking for the retail
culture also see some of his stand-up
comedy bits he's also posted about his
work on cocaine bear wouldn't you
several of his videos provided behind
the scenes look at the making of the
instant cold classic and to show his
followers what he went through to bring
the horror comedy to life in one such
video he gives viewers a look at the
making of the scene where the titular
bear pins into the ground through a door
naturally they didn't have a natural
bear there to intimidate cease but they
had the next best thing a regular dude
standing over him with a draw gun to
simulate saliva dripping onto his face
as if a real bear where they're about to
eat him in another shows how they filmed
him leaping into an ambulance and how
the vehicle takes off all the bear is in
Pursuit cease even refers to himself as
a daredevil and he certainly got put
through the ringer for his role in the
film and casting a tick tock star paid
off as he did indeed turn out to be
perfect for the role
[Music]